what's going on reject nation it's Greg
Alva here and I'm John so today we are
gonna check out a video from one of my
favorite YouTube channels of what
culture 9 theory is on how the Avengers
might disassemble la la la la but before
we do that we wanted to give a shout out
to our video sponsor today and that is
this app called quit if you guys like
things such as you know Bob's Burgers
Breaking Bad Rick and Morty I know John
does Buffy the Vampire Slayer five
nights at Freddy's Star Trek and of
course Marvel if you said yes to any or
one of these things and you're going to
love today's video sponsored quote
allows you to collect and share digital
stickers gifts trading cards
collectibles and you can even share them
with your friends and people all over
the world and they're all based on some
of your favorite TV shows movies and
video games you can track stickers and
cards in terms a rarity and build your
own unique collection across a variety
of themes and properties Plus quit has
its own keyboard so you can insert your
cards and gifts and stickers right into
your iMessages John definitely did that
while I was using the bathroom today I
did and new to the app they got tons of
Marvel stuff stickers and figures and
all sorts of things yeah they're pretty
rad and we're pretty excited to have
Marvel and a long time coming so if you
like what you see and you want to start
collecting you want to start sending
cool gifts and stuff to your friends hit
that link in the description box
download kwid today and jump on it's
available on Android and iOS a little
smoother for iOS at the moment but hey
join us it's awesome guys make sure to
download that and also last my leash
shout out today for none other than Kent
McKnight
the Marvel Cinematic Universe kicked off
in 2008 with Ironman and promises of an
epic team up to come but how will it end
nobody knows the answer to that question
with the future of Marvel's old guard
Captain America Iron Man Thor Black
Widow Hawkeye and Hulk uncertain there
have been rumors that the shared
Cinematic Universe has reached its end
game and that doesn't appear to be the
case films including the sequel to
spider-man homecoming at guardians of
the galaxy 2 are set to land in the
ensuing years so can anything stop this
super heroic juggernaut or will external
factors read to the universe untenable I
grew from what Coach I imagine is is 9
theories on how the Avengers might be
disassembled 9 the heroes bring peace to
the universe at the ending the Marvel
Cinematic Universe could one day reach a
rounded conclusion that sees the comic
book Giants mightiest heroes vanquish
all of their enemies and bring peace to
the universe fairness is unlikely to be
the ultimate big bad for the MCU in the
comic books he's a convex character
who's fought to save the galaxy almost
as many times as he's threatened it so
it seems this will replace the mad Titan
at the top of the food chain and raise
the stakes even higher planets Doctor
Doom this would be the ideal MCU final
boss fantasies our heroes unite but a
threat like Galactus would force
villains to join the alliance to anse
this new nemesis emerges we could be in
for another decade sort of a comic book
and a t' the universe is unmade there
are characters and artifacts in the
Marvel Universe powerful enough to
unmake reality from the Living Tribunal
to Thanos is fully stocked Infinity
Gauntlet there could come a time when
Marvel Studios feels a hard reboot is
needed iconic roles like Iron Man and
Cash America will need to be recast
probably sooner rather than later yeah
and the universe shattering event
presents the opportunity for an organic
reset a reboot could of course come many
years after the current cinematic
universes being concluded but Marvel has
the option to trigger a hard reset at
any time by having the final status
fingers or by encouraging the Living
Tribunal to pass judgment on
and seven a shift towards standalone
films rather than bringing the MC use
walls crashing down in apocalypse
optimistic retina face it out by
shifting back to standalone films is
happening already remember them is
ceasing their phase three will be
followed by something dramatically
different a for the MCU comic
adaptations we typically self-contained
dishing out a few installments before
rebooting and reloading the original
Avengers bought Earth's Mightiest Heroes
together civil war poured them apart
so perhaps infinity war and its sequel
oh god I love the answers are allowed
six bad reviews kill the series of any
film with the Marvel branding it's
guaranteed box-office gold and put
Norton's The Incredible Hulk is the
closest the MCU ever got to a flock and
eateth at mate two hundred and sixty
three point four million of a budget of
150 million so it's safe to say there's
little risk of ox office bombs being
it's unmaking but what about negative
reviews has been back now films obstruct
that sweet spot between critical acclaim
and commercial success but Hollywood is
awash with cautionary tales about how
quickly things can change
take the amazing spider-man franchise
for instance one minute Sony was
plotting its own cinematic universe but
next it was licking its wounds from a
critical battery sending Spidey back to
Marvel own to repair his fitted
reputation granted the MCU is built on
more solid foundations than Sony's spite
of this but could as a string of poorly
received movies [ __ ] our fans and
critics as its stories grow more complex
it's not unimaginable 5 the superhero
bubble I think I said yeah yeah yeah go
the way of the Western yeah between the
MCU it's DC competitor and Marvel's
x-men universe 5 to 7 major comic book
adaptations are released each year and
when the Western was in his heyday
oversaturation quickly set in critics
have been talking about the superhero
bubbles bursting since the 3rd entries
in the original spider-man and it
exactly
they evolved into an adamantium an IDE
haven't a Neum and adamantium eludes
Darrell it's weird that such - never
seems to die out entirely but shared
universe fatigue is a reality Marvel
must face against up being right and
Hollywood does fall out of love with
superheroism there's a chance Marvel
won't get to end the MCU on its own
terms for the MC use timeline is that's
more like like an exam only device
Marvel could use to shape its future
the firm's comic book arm has often used
time travel to rewrite his status
growing up the x-men she is notorious
for this and yes his movies dabbled with
it in Days of Future past an epic time
hopping crossover could be the only way
to bring the curtain down allowing
Marvel to surgically remove the heroes
it needs to retire either for
contractual reasons or because they just
far too old and final introducing a
character like can the Conqueror a
cosmic villain with the ability to
travel through the time and space would
help me see you on this one off and
dates back to the early days of Avengers
comics his ability to time heart could
be a game-changer
enabling sundresses every cool citizen
be really cool actually
this was made before the nez they fought
to the office video 12 comic content
Avengers vs. x-men would be an ideal way
to bring the two franchises together and
to close the MCU would have been
dismissed as folly
crossover events seem to get bigger in
scale is even more ambitious so bringing
together every character from the X
Universe and the MCU is the natural next
it's gonna change the X Man to put the
effort in they could wrap up two mega
franchises in style and pave the way for
a new age of superhero films - with TV
crossover if a crossover dual core I
reached with Fox perhaps Marvel could
look closer to home their cinematic and
TV universes have so far remain
separate but the comic-book giant could
finish them all in one big double whammy
whatever the MC used next big story line
is after Thanos it's bound to be even
more incredible with added daredevil
Jessica Jones and the Punisher like
Avengers vs. x-men it could be a real
status quo buster - this time across
both mediums this is the kind of stunt
Marvel should consider if they have any
hope of topping the first three phases
and one well in every our fans have
speculated about how the MCU might end
but what if it simply never does let's
face it there's no end in sight right
now even underwhelming Marvel films
pulling the kind of box office buck and
fresh reviews most other franchises
dream on the movie series neuromas
comics counterpart and these have been
running uninterrupted as an ongoing
interconnected story since the early
1960s granted they're big reboots
hardened soft at the books of always
existing
every time Spielberg's prophecy of doom
threatens to come to pass a movie like
guardians of the galaxy all Winter
Soldier comes along to prove just how
flexible photography is perhaps the
films will enjoy the same level of
longevity as the comics undergoing the
various restarts across generations but
always existing under one beautiful
banner a Marvel Cinematic Universe ok
well some of those are some good
theories some of them I just don't buy
like the world coming to a peaceful and
huh yeah they just make the war a peak a
peaceful place you know the universe is
way too vast I mean the universe is
unmade is a great way to do it but I
think the MCU is gonna continue on for a
while a long long time because I don't
agree with Spielberg's quote if you look
at western movies the problem with
western movies is they all sort of felt
like they were all following the same
tropes one thing about the MCU is while
they have a
beat sheet a structure that can
oftentimes be the same for their origin
movies specifically usually their
sequels will really mix it up the
sequels and the crossovers will really
mix it up and the DC movies are not the
same as the Marvel movies I know Disney
and Fox have not merged but the x-men
movies haven't been the same either when
you look at westerns a lot of the
westerns felt very similar so the
oversaturation I could see why Spielberg
would go at that go we'll look at my
westerns but I'm like now the western
genre was treated very differently in
terms of the way they were created so I
don't think it applies the same for
superhero genre when westerns are period
by design they harken back to something
very specific looking a very specific
bubble yeah and there are neo westerns
and stuff like that but obviously that's
not you know the prevalent Jean I feel
like superhero movies and Marvel movies
especially have improved the longevity
of this genre by mixing it up a lot
mixing and they also cross genre a lot
too which is the thing that keeps it
sustained I guess my concern
specifically in regards to the MCU
because what are we like 1718 films and
now with the MCU and they dish out like
three films a year this is a studio this
isn't just some this isn't a produced
franchise Marvel Studios I'm thinking
okay what about 20 to 30 years from now
when there's are they're still gonna be
MCU movies that are all in this one long
giant timeline because I think about the
longest-running franchise which is the
Bond franchise and the Bond franchise
the reason why I can continue on for so
long it's cuz its storyline isn't so
essential yeah you could never almost
almost never connected to the previous
movie yeah I mean and I remember when I
saw the first three Bond movies where
Connery they're connected but after a
while if it's a like Daniel Craig again
then they started contree connecting
them but even the Daniel Craig ones are
not the strongest connected ones like
Quantum of Solace too Casino Royale sure
but there's always like just little
things that are connected the MCU though
is so specific on its ties and on its
connection it's such a big part of what
makes the adventure so thrilling and
exciting and important I'm thinking well
what about when were 40 movies in and
there's all brand-new teenagers and are
they gonna have to go back
40 movies ago just so they could keep up
to date with everything yeah or are they
gonna like do a thing where every three
phases they soft reboot in a specific
way where a new generation can just hop
on board for these new films especially
when they start rebooting Ironman
getting new Ironman get a new Captain
America and all that that's one of the
things that made me think the most
during this video is that they are gonna
have to recast a lot of their main
players soon yeah I feel like they would
be smart to develop some kind of and I
and I believe they can develop some kind
of cycle I guess you call it yeah where
they do update it or refresh it or
figure out who's staying who needs to be
rebooted and how do we do that that
seems really tricky to me on the one
hand because it is so vast I don't know
if we'll ever get to a point cuz they
brought this up to about just standalone
films just like most of these films are
just standalone I and I don't feel like
we're gonna get to a point where it's
exactly that way I feel like another
step in this can be that they're gonna
start making smaller or more isolated
ones along with Elseworlds wood or
whatever Marvel's equivalent of that I
feel like it'll be necessary because of
the point I was bringing up the whole
thing about the excitement of the
characters crossing over is because
we're able to follow the timeline and
lineage of all these standalone
adventures and when they were in
previous movies before well when you're
like 4050 movies in and you got a whole
new generation of kids who are gonna be
wanting to watch this stuff and they
make a lot of this for kids oh I get the
toys and stuff yeah yeah I think you
will have to lean a little bit more on
standalone films new characters
rebooting with standalone films as well
I think they will do time fixing the
timeline or messing with time sure well
I will definitely figure in somewhere
and I like the idea I forget that
characters name but I like the idea of
doing it that way of bringing in some
kind of character whose whole thing is
space time yeah to mess things up and to
alter things I'm afraid that's gonna
become you know a go-to trope but at the
same time it seems like the handiest way
to reset a machine as big as this yeah I
really don't believe there's such a
thing as a superhero bubble that's gonna
burst
I mean negative reviews can affect it
cuz I mean we had a long ass discussion
like 3:00 in the morning last night
about the effect that rotten
has on movies and franchises now more
than we think yeah and and the audience
score on Rotten Tomatoes I mean if they
start getting consistently bad reviews I
don't think they're gonna go anywhere I
think they're just gonna try to find a
way to get it back up and make the
movies good again I think we got at
least a couple decades set for these
guys I really do I don't think the
bubble will burst ever entirely I don't
think we'll ever see a time in the near
future or where superhero movies aren't
a prevalent piece of the movie
marketplace just because to go back to
the Western argument they're very now
they're they're very right now and
they're very in the zeitgeist there's
there something that we love and there's
something that so many people have grown
up with over so much time complex have
been around for decades and plus the car
move ease they know how to adapt and
that's one of the best things in the
face of comments like that that they've
proven you know and I think that I don't
know if the bubble would ever burst
entirely but I can foresee a time where
maybe they're not quite so popular and
maybe we don't want six of them a year
yeah you know because there are a lot
and and I think we as a nerd culture
coming to the idea that there are a ton
of these moves so and there's so many
more we can make and so yeah there's so
many more characters and there's so many
and so I think part of this too is that
the kind of storytelling is gonna have
to update because there's only so many
times we can see a superhero a
traditional superhero movie I thought
we're gonna watch this movie it was
gonna be about how the Avengers in an
infinity war would disassemble I didn't
realize this was gonna be a video yeah I
didn't realize is gonna be about that
the MCU falling apart in a way I don't
feel like it the whole thing would ever
end and that's Marvel went down because
they get like they've done it they
brought up another good point is like
the way comics have been going for years
and years yeah and they're all kind of
cross pollinating with each other I feel
like Marvel has done a good job of
translating what the comic book
structure is to the visual the the
moving video medium and now that the MCU
has all the x-men and Fantastic Four man
is it's just gonna evolve and get
crazier and I think in some ways it
could get worse or better it's gonna be
one of the two and I bet there will be
growing pains but in the end they'll
probably just do with the comics because
if anything a lot of times their safety
net is be more loyal to
the comics yeah that's a safety net I
don't think that the MCU is gonna end in
tar leafless generations keep rolling
over yeah they're gonna be new
generations of Marvel fans and Marvel
movies are gonna change and wrapping
this up want to give a shout out to Kent
McKnight Kent Kent McKnight is one of
our patrons from Australia Australia
Australia Australia is that better
Australia Australia Australia we've done
two Google Hangouts with this guy he's
been so busy lately that we haven't had
a chance to hop on a Google hey guy
what's really interesting about this
dude is he has the pledge that qualifies
for him to be part of a Google hangout
hasn't been able to do it lately but yet
he's been so supportive and so kind that
he hasn't even lowered his pledge oh
that's amazing dude so really do
appreciate it I hope we can talk to you
again soon buddy and I hope you have a
really grand Merry Christmas and a Happy
Hanukkah if you're Jewish not Jewish in
in in hindsight I talked to him about
his religious beliefs happen if you have
no beliefs you celebrate Christmas the
way it goes we missed the hell out of
you because you're such a delightful
person to talk to you got such an
engaging smile I love you buddy and last
time we talked to you you were single I
hope now on Christmas or New Year's you
could stand on our mistletoe a little
and get a little suck any sucka Teac in
a love way in a love way he launches a
missile commercial of John's John's I
said cancel launches missiles hahaha
mistletoe I always thought mistletoe was
like what yeah the missiles the
reference
he's launching his missiles I don't
understand after the Sukkot II suck he's
launching his missiles I am oh yes this
innocuous metaphor that you've cofilin
it's completely appropriate metaphor it
doesn't mean anything
all right guys well thanks for tuning in
you can subscribe to the real rejects
subscribe to walk culture while you're
at it make sure to check out our patron
become a patron eject today it's like a
second youtube channel a lot of
discussion vids over there and last but
not least make sure to follow that link
and check out quit yeah we got the app
right now get yourself some Marvel
sticker
Blanchard marvel Funko pop dear best
friends while they're pooping yeah cuz
that's what he does